Now recall from our previous lectures, where we
had basically talked about how computational photography is a process that takes
information from a three-dimensional scene, and goes through a series of
different steps to be able to generate an image that a user can interact with.
So in the whole traditional aspect of computational photography,
we start 3D scene, that is illuminated, optics is used to be able to
get information from the scene onto a sensor, which converts it into pixels.
And we've looked at in detail how image processing techniques can take
the pixels for enhancement or even for analysis of images, like finding features
that would be then used for various computational photography processes.
The thing I want everybody to remember is, what we're interested in is going
from rays of light in a 3D scene, and going to be able to
generate pixels that can be used for various types of computational processes.
Of course, we want the computational processes to also impact illumination,
optics, sensor, not just image processing.
So, one thing I want to emphasize also is that, in the study of computational
photography, we do rely on various types of disciplines, ranging from optics,
sensors, computer vision, computer graphics and
image processing, and they impact each and every aspect of this pipeline,
of we're trying to get information all the way from 3D scenes,
to actually generate an image that could be processed and displayed.
And these are the disciplines that we have, kind of will be studying in
different details to help us build the foundations of computational photography.
We already looked at image processing to kind of help us extract
information from images, but we will be looking at more scene analysis and
stuff like that from optics and also from computer vision.
And we'll study things like sensors, especially camera sensors and
how light is actually captured.